для проведення виборів з України
по війну буде окуповано і на мені
весь до але it'sa вишиті тон барс
то і моя видно в цей контроль на все
справі антиросійську українську кордону
сепаратисти might припаяні ти зброю ну
так навчають і політичну боротьбу за владу
кримінально продумала вибір фбр specs
створ чути в бсмп above the best in
green дат мос еспа стоячий мати без
порошку одне без до звали в неї оружня
ними
а ось абсолютно абсолютно пресувати
територію ще на іміджі захисту ж не
вдовий barium з постригу.
голосуванням за крима парламентарії щодо
ви дні мати можна їсти і самі
вибори мати but і організованіша
адже видно і стандарті на обидва з
хвірткою та стандарт
з цілей, а не хлопчики, експерти почали
зуби з їжі скупити в берліні, що мої
зуби то україна для повинності
виборі в захисних стандартах кліпу ви
нам забути почитав і ви його не на
дні леона внутрішніх переселенців
українські політичні сили мати вранці
це можна мабуть від осі за владу на
донбасі а українська за особливо масовою
інформації з виймати з можуть
пиріжкового світліють і вибір чу компанію
для тієї ранку базу криму замість зради в
український вибір чаю законодавству та
abundance
вона петра ми за ікла йому вигляд
побачили і за ці сторони ще наш краще
провести закону та вчора форми і над
розхитати шас його приховані дж але мало
щоб нас правді
до секції прогресу аджі налити його
стане нижнім і занепалому чесного ведуть
люди багато вибуваються з точкою доступу
стріляти чого станемо і ти ж ними знову
у складні вся пахта і на обличчі двох він,
швед ось місць україна мусять ви куди ти
все вигадувати для підготовки вибору
вчені пісні шадо кінсей алип не поважає
німецькі експерти колорадо євросоюзу
хвалю в цьому і рішеннях диво подалі в
санкцій проти росії і наші ти снуд і
на кремль буду ваш чин я може вже
добрий я витягну з російських інтересів
як че харчування виборі затягнутися до
тієї години
to dive нас можна представити україну
собі лише вони ж раніше я кацапові
делайла
ви на гівне ваккун вони мінських
домовленостей задум експерта про
виборах нас правді затікала не всі
сторони україни для повертання упакованих
територій піци контроль сепаратисти
для легітимізації влади Росія що
представить і конфлікт на сході України
як внутрішній політичний, а за hit
рахунок наріжте ліквіду вати пруха водичку
у собі на кордонах